we want to get right to an exclusive
here this morning we've got an interview
as you can see with former Republican
Congressman will Hurd Congressman Hurd
thank you very much for joining us
you've got a distinguished career in
service you uh we're an undercover CIA
officer and you were elected to congress
from your home District I think you
served three terms uh six years and you
join us today with an announcement why
don't you take it away sure well thanks
for the opportunity and I want to let
everybody know that this morning I filed
to be the Republican nominee for
president of the United States this is a
a decision that my wife and I decided to
do because we live in complicated times
and we need Common Sense there are a
number of generational defining
challenges that we're faced with in the
United States of America everything from
the Chinese government trying to surpass
us as the global superpower the fact
that inflation is persistent at a time
when Technologies like artificial
intelligence is going to upend every
single industry and our kids or their
scores and math science and reading are
the lowest they've ever been in this
Century these are the issues we should
be talking about and to be frank I'm
pissed that we're not talking about
these things I'm pissed that our elected
officials are telling us to to hate our
neighbors right our neighbors are not
our enemies they're our fellow Americans
who we just happen to have a
disagreement with these are the issues
that that we should be talking about and
I believe the Republican Party can be
the party that talks about the future
not the past we should be putting out a
vision of how do we have unprecedented
peace how do we have a thriving economy
how do we make sure our kids have a
world-class education regardless of
their age or location we can do this
it's hard but here's where the thing I
learned if we remember two things we can
pull this off America is better together
and way more unites us than devices we
all know that but that just doesn't seem
to be the case you'd be the 12th
Republican to get into the race you're
considered common sense moderate how in
the world Congressman do you break
through when everything is so hyper
partisan people are so angry and you
know everybody says Donald Trump clearly
leads the pack at this point how in the
world do you break through at this time
so someone like me right a dark horse
candidate can pull this off one you
can't be afraid of Donald Trump too many
of these candidates in this race are
afraid of Donald Trump but we also have
to articulate a different vision
all of my life I've heard that the
Republican party was the big tent party
that we were the party that was willing
to have competition of ideas but
unfortunately we have gotten in this
Echo chamber and only preach the choir
it's real easy preaching to the choir
but what we need to be able to do is
grow the choir you have to do that in a
primary you have to do that in general
election and guess what I know how to do
that nobody thought a black Republican
was going to win in a 72 percent Latino
District against another Republican who
had a lot of money and everybody was
backing him but I was able to pull it
off because I did something simple
show up to places where people don't
expect you talk about the things they
care about right and and that's the path
it's not easy and is the path narrow
absolutely but it's something that we
have to do because it's too important
that what we have to accomplish and you
recently said that um president the
presidential election between former
president Donald Trump and President
Biden is a rematch from hell now you
just talked about I'm talking about
something I'd say that sounds like
something you say um now what are your
thoughts on on President Biden and how
would you differentiate yourself from
him well look the fact that seven out of
10 Americans do not want to see
President Biden on the ballot in six out
of 10 Americans do not want to see
Donald Trump that is that that is a
reason people want something different I
think the first thing we're going to be
different is how do you deal with the
Border what's happening at the border is
a crisis now I will say this actually
started under Donald Trump from failed
policies under Donald Trump and Joe
Biden continued those failed policies
when 2.5 million people came into our
country illegally last year that is
basically fueling human traffickers so
how do you how do you control the border
and the one important aspect of that
which is actually streamlining legal
immigration and here's why you're never
going to see Joe Biden streamline legal
immigration it's the same reason you
never saw Nancy Pelosi do it because the
far left of their party and organized
labor do not want to see guest worker
programs they do not want to see those
things so we start there and this is a
complicated issue that you have to
address root causes in the places where
this is this is coming from right so so
those and and you do all those things I
just outlined you don't need
Congressional approval to do it this is
stuff that you can be doing on day one
in the executive Congressman before we
get to Joe Biden you've got to go
through uh Donald Trump uh something
that all the Republicans running to be
the nominee have to do is take a
position on this indictment this
unprecedented indictment of former
president Donald Trump I'm sure you've
read it what's your opinion of it my
opinion is first off I'm talking by the
way since there are two indictments
there's one at the state level uh
especially as a former CIA officer
the classified documents case as a
former CA officer nobody's Above the Law
and you are innocent until proven guilty
would you however no I would not pardon
him and people that are talking about
pardoning him right now when the case
hasn't even started is insane to me and
and here is here is why that this is
frustrating to me
Donald Trump knew the kinds of
information that he had and when you
look at the classifications of these
documents these are information and if
it got in the wrong hands would lead to
a loss of life that is what makes this
case different and the fact that Donald
Trump willingly kept that material and
he wants to be the leader of the Free
World is unacceptable to me now this has
to go through a court case but as Bill
Barr said if if one of these things is
true
it's incredibly damning and it spits in
the face
of the thousands of men and women who
every single day and every single night
put themselves In Harm's Way in order to
keep us safe right and so so to me that
is that is unacceptable and we have to
stop listening to these lies and the
fact that he said he kept this because
he wanted to get his golf shorts back
Congressman he's just outrageous this is
not necessarily going to grow the
Republican primary base for you your
comments right now you still consider
yourself to be a a born and bred Rock
rib Republican absolutely I'm a
Republican and here is here is here is
the actual reality when you go and talk
to people right this is the difference I
get on the ground I engage with folks
and and and I learned representing a
district that was larger than 26 States
right that it took ten and a half hours
to drive across across it and whether I
was in a ruby red District or a deep
blue District people talk about the same
things they wanted issues about how am I
going to be able to put food on my table
a roof over my head and take care of the
people that I that I love yeah I
remember when you did the road trip with
beta O'Rourke so we know that you know
how to play nicely with others you just
got married recently so congratulations
you've got your work cut out for you
we're glad you chose us to do it many
many people do lights camera action yeah
to make a crowded field it's a crowded
field yeah I know this won't be the last
time we see you at the table thank you
very much thank you very much